le coronavirus continue sa propagation à
travers le monde et en europe en
particulier et le président russe même
s'il reconnaît la gravité de la
situation a tenu à se montrer rassurant
grâce aux mesures anticipées prise
rapidement au niveau régional et fédéral
dans les premières semaines de
l'épidémie dans le monde
nous avons réussi à empêcher la
contagion et la propagation massive
je souligne massive du virus en russie
actuellement bien que le niveau de
risque soit potentiellement élevé il
faut le souligner et je vais y revenir
de façon générale la situation est sous
contrôle
du côté du secteur hospitalier
l'état des lieux est fait en prenant en
compte les différents scénarios
possibles
nous avons inventorié toutes les
ressources disponibles susceptibles
d'être utilisés en cas d'infection par
le coronavirus nous disposons de plus de
40000 système de respiration
artificielle
à l'heure actuelle nous produisons
chaque jour jusqu'à 100000 test de
détection du coronavirus alors bien sûr
dans le sillage des autres pays touchés
par la pandémie
la russie a également adopté des mesures
pour commencer depuis ce mercredi et
jusqu'au 1er mai les autorités ont fermé
le territoire russe aux citoyens
étrangers
en parallèle les citoyens russes bloqués
à l'étranger sont priés de se signaler
auprès de la mission diplomatique la
plus proche afin d'organiser leur retour
à moscou tous les événements extérieurs
ont été interdits et les écoles et
universités fermées les rassemblements
en espace confiné eux sont limitées à un
maximum d'une cinquantaine de personnes
les autorités ont aussi décidé de
suspendre les compétitions sportives
alors que la russie était l'un des
derniers pays d'europe à ne pas l'avoir
encore fait mais comme partout ailleurs
des grandes surfaces moscovites ont été
prises d'assaut en cause les rumeurs de
confinement total de la capitale russe
en raison de la diffusion d'informations
dans les médias affirmant qu'une mise en
quarantaine serait imposé à moscou
je voudrais souligner que ces
informations sont fausses je vous
exhorte à consulter les informations
officielles fournies par le groupe de
travail pour éviter la panique et ce
genre de comportement vladimir points
dit miser sur une chose la transparence
pour modèle il est absolument essentiel
d'éliminer toute possibilité de rumeurs
nocives sans fondement et surtout de
spéculations malveillantes autour de ce
sujet mais pour cela on ne peut s'y
opposer qu'avec des information fiable
et complète fournie en temps voulu le
gouvernement se veut pour l'heure
rassurant tandis que la pandémie semble
n'avoir pas encore frappé la russie
aussi durement que ses voisins européens